to help celebrate our 11 years of shows
at tbs
we're putting together montages of some
of our favorite show highlights
tonight we're going to check out some
great moments from one of my
all-time favorite people on this planet
mr andy richter take a look what do you
think of this heat andy
oh how to declare mr o'brien
it's hotter than two pigs fighting over
a chili pepper
you see whenever it gets really hot
outside
andy has a strange allergic reaction
that turns him into an old southern
gentleman
hopeful
oh tonight
i'm really worried that andy's becoming
more southern
by the second i hope it's over soon i
ain't afraid of you serpent
you may have tempted eve but your venom
cannot penetrate me
we have to focus on getting andy's heat
allergy under control
and just hope this doesn't get any i'm
beginning to think you boys don't want
to go to regions
mcgill away are you a jewish person
cause it seems like you're afraid to get
your hands on a little pig skin are you
gonna drink the whole thing
who said anything about drinking it
snack slappers
[Music]
right down in here all right saddle up
next to this brush
here's right here coming to you
they're both gone let's get out of here
now that we're in murky water together i
feel like there's no secrets between us
no there shouldn't be no
no in all the years i've been in tv
right now is the first time i've ever
been peeing while on tv
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll tell you the titles of all 18 of my
memoirs
side dish confessions of a talk show
sidekick
then we've got sidekick to the curb the
andy richter story
sidetracked a life less lived
oh you care do you well then why don't
you do something for me
why don't you tell me what your son's
name is
[Music]
so what is it he doesn't know
he'll never know that's why i gave up on
him years ago
and i suggest you do the same mom
derek derrick
his name is heaven you jackass
oh this is a good one that's me in the
corner
good one boss my life is a tv toady
fake laughter real tears a sidekick's
journey okay
okay andy i think we get the idea
there's 11
more i'm here speaking to
one of the stars the lone ranger
you of all people should know how
important it is to have a shallow brown
noser out here
[Laughter]
forcing the laugh hiding the gin bottle
my lectern my prison
andrew and the terrible horrible no good
very bad career
waiting for that guy to shut up so i can
go home the andy richter story
20 feet from dum-dum
[Applause]
is murder legal yet just curious
a wheel of fortune contestant has gone
viral
after making a wildly inappropriate
guess
yeah the answer was kicking back but she
guessed chasing
tail that show is always trying to trick
you into guessing something
inappropriate
it's happened to me so many times look
at this tape
okay pat i'm gonna solve it the
stops here you are so close
the answer is the buck stops here
i think i better solve it pat
goose not even close
of the draw no of the irish
be a lady tonight are you serious
in the saddle again in the box
the quarter sam
mighty may the be with you
joy club long haul
puppet finger good thomas the
engine
fuckish curl up with a good
dwayne the johnson starbucks
monster rally buckingham palace
green bay
[Applause]
are you sure happy national waffle day
everybody
[Applause]
it was yesterday not today
well give them back come on get back on
waffles
[Applause]
[Laughter]
people started throwing them people
started
throwing them back at you
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
oh oh
[Applause]
okay